to most people mushroom clouds mean
nuclear explosions the threat of
radioactive fallout of mutually assured
destruction and at the end of the world
but they don't have to be any large
enough explosion will cause a mushroom
cloud and it's happened in Britain right
here this crater was once raf old an old
mining operation converted to an
underground bomb storage depot for the
Royal Air Force underground storage was
meant to be safer one of the problems
with munitions dumps is that the enemy
just needs to hit them with one bomb and
the whole lot goes up this site seemed
perfect but there was a problem because
this was built in the 1930s for small
bombs the sort of one person can carry
the sort that you can move on a conveyor
belt the sort that the army can fire
from a field gun across the trenches
that's why these old quarry's with all
their tunnels and caverns were perfect
but then the Second World War moved on
and bombing became a job for the Air
Force and the bombs got bigger and
bigger and bigger
fast half a tonne one ton two tons and
the war effort needed many many more
bombs than have been predicted rapid
changes in supply and demand meant that
the underground depots were filled far
beyond anything like their original
capacity by the end of 1944 the men here
at RAF old words storing stacks of high
incendiary bombs outside the mine until
they could find space inside there was a
war on they had to make it work Monday
27th of November 1944 the commanding
officer with on leave the officer
responsible for the underground stores
was also on leave and it was his
deputies day off to everyone who was
down in the depot and in charge was
inexperienced and massively overworked
according to the official inquiry
someone tried to remove a detonator from
a live bomb with a brass chisel and
brush chisels cause sparks in Morocco
1,500 miles away seismographs recorded
what felt like a distant earthquake a
hundred miles away people heard a rumble
carried on the wind for miles away a
shockwave blasted out
windows and here a mushroom cloud rose
into the sky
4000 tons of bombs had gone up in one
terrible chain reaction the largest
explosion ever in the British Isles this
crater was once a hill with a farmhouse
on top of it
no trace of that farmhouse all the
people who lived there was ever found
the bombs that hadn't immediately
exploded were thrown into the air and
rained down for miles around along with
millions of tons of debris and nearby
dam collapsed sending flood waters down
into factories and houses in the nearby
valley the exact death toll will never
be known at least 60 perhaps 90 it took
months before all the bodies were
recovered and some were never found
and in the air force reports held
classified for years and years after the
explosion along with the names of the
dead and page after page itemizing every
bit of the destruction there is this
phrase columns of black smoke and debris
rose in gigantic mushroom form when
you're rushed when you're inexperienced
anyone can get complacent anyone can cut
corners anyone can make a mistake even
when you're working with high explosives
now slowly over years the crater was
cleared and reclaimed decades later what
remains is an armed star on the
landscape about half the bombs store
actually managed to survive the
explosion and while the bombs were
removed there are still tunnels and
storage rooms hidden under the crater
but after careless explorers started
damaging the site all the known
entrances were filled in and given the
warnings about unexploded bombs still in
the crater I'm not about to climb this
fence and go any further there is one
little interesting note though right at
the end of the story through the late
40s in the 1950s the American military
kept asking for records and details of
the explosion how big was it exactly
what was the damage to the nearby land
and was it by earthquake or by blast
wave what happens if you essentially
detonate something with the yield of a
tactical nuclear bomb underground
Britain never answered and America went
on to make its own mushroom cloud